hey guys dr. Berg here in this short video
we're going to talk about the amazing health
benefits of consuming beets now it is true that
beets are higher in sugar but in the fiber that
they have as a whole unit if you were to shred
them on your salad I think that would be okay
okay it's not going to be that big of a deal so
what I like to do is I like to take the tops off
the beets first wash them and freeze them and
I use those in like in my kale shake I'll mix
kale parsley with beet tops and I'll add a
little bit of berries blend it up and oh my
gosh that will really help help your liver okay
so that's one thing then the actual beat itself
you can shave them in your salad I like to get
different color beets I'll get the purple beet
I'll get the yellow beet I'll get the red beet
and I'll just use them and I just love them so
these are the benefits there's something in
your liver that allows toxins to be turned
into harmless particles so basically the liver
has certain enzymes to break down chemicals
okay and the beets improve that process to the
point where it helps you detoxify chemicals in
the liver so it's really good and liver beets
also are high in antioxidants they're high in
choline they're high in certain nutrients that
dissolve fat on your inside your liver so if
you have a fatty liver you want to consume beets
okay so they have a lot of great properties to fix
the liver and the gallbladder they will improve
the exits estrogen the liver and also indirectly
raised some testosterone levels to balance it
out it won't give you too much testosterone
but it balances out to a normal level because
to testosterone works with the liver so it's
a really good hormonal balancer so it will
decrease estrogen and increase testosterone
giving you better workouts more endurance more
stamina okay blood pressure really good too it
has nitric oxide which relaxes the arteries
in the cardiovascular system to lower blood
pressure it's another good benefit right and it's
good anti-inflammatory so again start using these
on your salad in your shakes and it's going to
really provide some really cool benefits to your
your body and also click the link below I have a
quiz down there you can take that will allow you
to find out what's really going on with your body
and will send you the report thanks for watching